without comes the leader of the SMP Ian
Blackfoot
thank you Mr Speaker and can I associate
myself with the remarks of the Prime
Minister on the murder of David Amos a
year ago and thoughts and prayers very
much with Julia and and his family and
of course uh we thank very much of those
in Christopher that have been caught up
in the incredible tragedy there as well
I would have hoped that if the prime
minister is making public spending
commitments today that she would have
said that those that rely on Social
Security benefits will get the benefits
operated in life Mr Speaker when the
Prime Minister last stood at the
dispatch box the average two-year fixed
rate mortgage stood at four and a half
percent
they're now at six and a half percent in
Rising hitting average families with an
extra
450 pounds a month of mortgage payments
every single month over and above what
they were paying 37 days into the job
this is literally the cost of the prime
minister's incompetence it is the price
households are paying and all because of
the chancellor that she chose exactly
well she now give up her desperate plan
to save her chance of her skin by
scapegoating the governor of the bank of
England
that is
Mr Speaker the action we have taken has
meant that families in Scotland and
across the United Kingdom are not facing
gargantuan energy bills and what the
honorable gentleman and his friends in
Scotland could do to help us out is
build the nuclear power stations
get more gas out to the North Sea to
help deliver on a more secure Energy
Future for all of our people
up Mr Speaker that she wants to ask us
questions we can swap places
the reality is Mr Speaker that the prime
minister is ignoring the damage of the
chaos of the mini budget she's worrying
about saving the Chancellor's job but
many families are now worried not just
about hitting their homes but keeping
their homes the scale of this Tory
crisis is frightening 100
000 households a month are up for
mortgage renewals people can't afford to
pay an extra four and a half thousand
pounds a year in interest and plenty are
already falling behind the Prime
Minister and her Chancellor have
completely lost control the only thing
growing under this government are
mortgages rents and bills is that what
she really meant when she declared
herself a pro-growth prime minister
[Applause]
well we have taken action on helping
families Heat their homes and that's
been very important and I would love to
see more support on delivering the
energy security we need interest rates
arising globally that is a fact and
interest rates are a decision for the
Independent Bank of England but I want
to do all I can to help families across
Britain but the way we're going to help
them is by delivering economic growth by
making sure we have the jobs and
opportunities in Scotland and right
across the UK and what independent
forecasters have shown is that following
our intervention economic growth is
going to be higher than it would have
been if we hadn't acted and that is
vitally important for the jobs the
opportunities and the livelihoods and
helping make sure people are able to put
food on the table
[Applause]